speaking on Ukrainian state television
president Petro poroshenko said he
turned to Berlin after the Kremlin
failed to respond to his request for
dialogue Achieva immediately that night
I ordered a phone conversation with the
President of Russia Vladimir Putin we
did not receive any response and I had
to turn to the German Chancellor so that
she could talk to Putin on the immediate
release of Ukrainian servicemen and
Ukrainian ships poroshenko also said the
authorities would take all necessary
steps to release the Ukrainian sailors
detained on Sunday when Russia seized
three vessels off the Crimean coast
captured sailors appeared in a Russian
Court and were charged with unlawfully
entering the country carrying weapons
they face up to six years in prison
earlier other sailors were shown on
Russian television saying they had
deliberately entered Russian waters as a
provocation Kiev denounced what it
described as forced confessions Moscow
accuses Kiev of sparking the sea
skirmish to boost support ahead of an
election most probably this provocation
took place in order to achieve certain
political decisions which have been
official for the current president of
Ukraine Ukraine accuses Russia of
illegally capturing its ships and
sailors off the coast of Crimea
President Petro poroshenko now claims
Moscow is preparing for an invasion
together with the country's parliament
he has imposed martial law in the
regions bordering Russia for 30 days
fundamentally the whole martial law is
about getting the resources together and
for everybody here in Ukraine to
understand his or her place when the
Russians come frozen
president poroshenko insisted the
measures won't interfere with elections
scheduled for March but his decree is
causing concern and confusion in the
capital Kiev for Ukrainians it's unclear
what changes martial law will bring
after a four-year standoff with Russia
peace seems a distant outcome our
correspondent Nick Conley joins us now
from the yukine Ukrainian capital Kiev
first of all Nick there seems to be some
confusion about whether martial law is
actually in effect in Ukraine or not is
Ukraine under martial law good morning
Terry well we were expecting to wake up
to have all of this some clarity after
all these days of confusion and yet the
the guessing goes on so it seems like
the law needed to put this into effect
has still not been signed neither by the
president nor by the chairman of
Ukraine's Parliament who it seems isn't
even in the country to do so so a lot of
question marks there even some confusion
as to whether it might have been applied
retroactively ly by an order by the
president so we're hoping to understand
more today but even if it does come into
effect we still don't know the actual
real effect on everyday Ukrainians lives
how this is going to affect people what
civil liberties will be affected so a
lot of question marks still open okay
well let's look more closely now at the
crisis itself
president poroshenko there in Ukraine he
says he's going to use all means
necessary to secure the release of those
captured Ukrainian sailors that we saw
in our report but what could that mean
all means necessary I think no one's
suggesting that he's really proposing
some kind of military pressure on Russia
given how clearly clearly Russia has
military superiority but I think this
means everything from economic to
diplomatic pressure using Ukraine's
links to its Western partners to try and
bring pressure to bear on Russia so
those sailors now in Russian custody for
at least two months on charges of
illegally crossing the border Ukraine's
position has always been and still is
that this is illegitimate
on the part of Russia that Ukraine
has the right to pass those straits of
Kurt and that Russia is no position to
decide who has access to the sea of azov
now you mentioned Western pressure Nick
poroshenko says he requested a dialogue
with Putin didn't get a response and has
turned to Berlin for help what more can
you tell us about that well quite
extraordinary scenes are described by
present poroshenko that call that was
rejected by the Kremlin on the weekend
we heard yesterday from the Kremlin that
they had rejected official offers of
mediation from Germany but it's clear
that this is not going to be resolved at
a bilateral level besides just aren't
talking to each other what form that
will take whether that be some kind of
more formalized set up for now that
seems the Kremlin isn't interested but
this communication is not going to
happen between Kiev and Moscow it's
going to have to involve Ukraine's
Western partners and I think that's
something that Kiev is hoping for Nick
thank you very much for that update our
correspondent Nick Conley there in Kiev